me and the drew's news team love food so
much that we gave it a whole segment
called
food news and it has a graphic and a
sound effect
and everything it's my fave and in honor
of our
little bit extra hour here are a few of
our favorite
drew's news food moments and say
that three times fast that we thought
warranted a little bit of an extra look
so let's watch let's kick it off with
cake of the day
please today
it's the nunchi jelly cake
this is not your mama's jelly mold these
retro cakes are making a comeback
and this one was made for us by lexi
park from california
she makes 200 of these little jigglers
check out her instagram and her website
eatnchi.com
i mean come on i just i can't stop
jiggling
i don't know if you're ready for that
jelly cake i am my beer
[Applause]
you got your bag joe joellen oh yes i do
okay so trader joe's the mad scientist
of snacks they have a brand new item
called the everything but the bagel
kettle chip now you know they have the
seasoning there at trader joe's
you can put on everything everything but
the bagels like everything oh this is
actually trader joe's like um personal
seasoning yeah
it's just yeah uh-huh and it's amazing
but now they have it on a chip
i got my grandma a bag so that she can
taste along with us while she's watching
so what's your grandmother i'm excited
to get her her name actually is
joellen pelman i was named after my
grandma
so it's joe ellen we love both joellens
all right ready here we go ready yes
whoa everybody tell us
something you taste joellen you go first
i i weirdly feel like i'm eating an
everything bagel because i taste cream
cheese
you know what i taste on an everything
bagel when they toast it and it kind of
burns the garlic and gets a little like
bitter
yes that's what i'm taking in like a
great way yes
burnt garlic i'm also getting butter
i think it's our mind playing bagel
tricks with us what would you put on a
bagel
brock's announced its newest seasonal
treat
turkey dinner candy corn brock's has
given us the thanksgiving dinner no one
really asked for
in every bag there's flavors like
cranberry sauce green beans stuffing
my favorite can't get enough of it and
roast turkey
okay so i've got my tiny little
thanksgiving right here
vffs who's ready to feast with me jason
hi drew hi jason hello
you ready to try this i'm doing it i've
got my bag
i think i have a turkey here it goes
what color are you doing all right i go
for down the hatch
it's the yellow it's the yellow top
brown bottom
yeah that's turkey
i think i got like pumpkin pie because
mine's really sweet and it's actually
really good
well you i'm not saying this is bad but
definitely meaty
[Applause]
delish reports that
now you can get your very own stoppers
lasagna fanny pack have your lasagna on
the go with this great holiday gift
you strap it on and you open it up and
manja
some piping hot waste lasagna ready
because
i'm just saying so basically
first of all i love fanny packs and to
all you women out there
they're a really great way to keep track
of your fluctuating weight
fanny pack tightened good day fanny pack
lucen
not a great day i am just going to
yep there it is you know
i'm so sorry i'm just a little hungry
just gonna
[Applause]
[Music]
number
you